make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
all right what's going on guys this is
rob and welcome back to comics explained
a youtube channel where i will make you
a comic book expert in 30 minutes
or less and in this video i'm gonna make
you guys an expert on loki or at least
one part of loki
more like classic loki okay so here's
the thing in marvel comics loki has
three or four different eras or versions
of his character there is the original
loki as he appeared in marvel comics
which we as comic book fans kind of
refer to as classic loki or just loki
and then you have j michael cerzinski's
run which gave us
lady loki and then you have the
aftermath of siege on asgard which gave
us kid loki and then you have aikol
who's
more of an interesting character i kind
of consider him to be a return to form
for the character of loki so in this
video what we're actually going to find
here is we're going to kind of start off
in the early days of stanley and jack
kirby's run we'll go into a little bit
of discussion about walt simonsen and
then we'll actually kind of jump
all the way to about the last two years
of marvel comics and then kind of wrap
it up and the reason for
this is because loki as we know him in
his classic form originally debuted back
at marvel comics in
journey into mystery number 85 in
october of 1962. now one of the funny
things about this
is that in these early stories by stan
lee and jack kirby the idea of loki
existing was really more based on the
notion that he was an adopted son from
the frost giants and that was it right
we didn't really get a whole lot in
terms of how it was that went down
it was just somewhere along the line
odin came into conflict with the frost
giants and that was basically it then he
adopted loki what we ended up getting
in j michael cerzinski's run on thor and
we'll talk about that a little bit in
this video and then we'll talk more
about it in the next video that we do on
lady loki um you kind of got this story
whereby loki essentially went back and
guaranteed his own adoption
and this kind of played out in the sense
that loki ended up making a deal with uh
hella and then traveled into the past
and encountered the father of odin a guy
by the name of boar
and during this time loki essentially
destroyed boer's physical form
and then kept his kind of spiritual
essence locked in ice or at least it was
ultimately trapped in ice
following that loki took on the
appearance of bore as as essentially a
ghost with odin having witnessed his his
father's death
and then in turn informed odin that he
needed to go adopt a child from
you know one of his greatest villains
one of his greatest enemies which
ultimately turned out to be laffy from
the frost giants and of course
that's how loki was adopted but one of
the things that i want to specify here
is that in these early stories loki was
not particularly
interesting and i guess it really kind
of depends on on what you find to be
interesting
in comics for me personally i never
found him to be really enjoyable or fun
it wasn't really until you got into
strazinski's thor run that he became a
really cool character so basically lady
loki going forward so a lot of the the
early things were basically loki being a
trickster right and not really being
exceedingly violent
more just kind of messing with thor
causing some problems here and there and
the reason for this is because
stan lee and jack kirby didn't really
believe in telling
exceedingly violent stories for the sake
of violence
i mean they did have stories where
characters would die or things along
those lines but there was an interview
that stan lee had done
where he kind of talked about this idea
that if a character was going to die
it needed to be something of
significance and so he wanted comics in
a lot of ways to be this kind of escape
from reality these sort of flights of
fantasy
that's one of the things that
differentiated marvel from dc in the
early days
is that in the 70s dc was dealing with
characters like barry allen's wife iris
dying and different things like that and
marvel did that a little bit right the
death of gwen stacy in 1971 but the
important thing here is prior to that
point
you didn't really see that kind of stuff
all that often it was more or less kind
of the struggle of what it meant to be a
hero
a lot of this was predicated on the
success of the fantastic four and so
carrying that into the thor
stories the notion of thor kind of being
this dual personality right where you
had donald blake who was the regular guy
modeled off the superman clark kent
persona over at dc comics right the
alter ego
and then thor who was basically the
superhero and so because of that when
loki's initially introduced to us
because of the various schemes and the
kind of things that he had gotten into
over the years he was basically locked
inside of a tree the stance of odin here
was you are basically going to stay in
this tree
until somebody sheds a tear for you and
what ended up happening is loki used his
powers to
shake a leaf loose which fell into the
eye of heimdall and heimdall cried but
because heimdall cried due to the
actions of loki loki was basically freed
from the tree and that kind of trickery
that kind of deception and sort of
manipulation to a degree despite it
being light-hearted was essentially
a hallmark of loki's character going
forward in marvel comics now again for
the old stan lee and jack kirby's
stories loki was okay and he did some he
did some relatively important things you
know i don't want to kind of skim over
it i don't want to throw out this idea
that loki had no real significance in
marvel comics back during the stan lee
and jack kirby era he did and in fact
there were two
major stories that took place uh during
this point in time the first as most of
you guys know is avengers number one and
the second one came and journeyed into
mystery number 114 in 1965 right so
looking to avengers number one for those
of you guys who are unaware here what
essentially happened is
loki had basically manipulated the
incredible hulk and set him on a rampage
and the result of this is that the
kind of non-mutant landscape of marvel
comics and excluding the fantastic four
ultimately had to team up so you got
thor you got ant-man
you got a name on the submariner you got
these different characters you got wasp
who all kind of teamed up and said okay
like they defeated the incredible hulk
and then at the end of the story that
gave birth to the avengers right and so
that's kind of where the avengers came
from in marvel the journey into mystery
114 is more of an
unsung story and actually gave birth to
a
villain that marvel misused for decades
and has only recently
turned into somebody interesting and
that's the absorbing man crusher creole
so the absorbing man the way this played
out is crusher creel had been serving a
prison sentence
and loki was looking to create a villain
for thor
that could face off against him quite
readily and just kind of allow loki to
sit back and wait for thor to be
destroyed which is kind of a hallmark of
his character at this point in time the
result of this is that he concocted a
potion that was full of asgardian herbs
and things like that
and then fed it to crusher creel
secretly and then when crusher creel
drank this this kind of potion he was
able to essentially turn into any
material he touched now as you can
probably guess
the potential for that is astounding
it's incredible
but marvel never really did a whole lot
with it and in fact i would go as far as
to say
that it wasn't really until al ewing
took up the pin in writing immortal hulk
that crusher creel became a far more
interesting character that's
only really being explored to his
fullest potential now
some you know 40 or 50 years after his
creation almost and so again you know
these early stories
largely dealt with loki doing things
like snatching up jane foster
and then using her as some kind of pawn
or holding her hostage and then facing
off against thor and then sometimes thor
would lose his hammer temporarily and
then you know loki would do something to
manipulate thor thor would get his
hammer back it was one of these very
much kind of cat-and-mouse situations
and the family dynamic was played up
pretty heavily by stan lee and jack
kirby right in the sense that loki would
engage in some scheme
he'd be defeated by thor he'd be handed
over to odin odin would lock him away
inside of like a stone or something like
that loki would find a way to escape and
he would go right back to it again just
over and over and over and over again
the reality is that the process of loki
becoming really
interesting in marvel comics didn't
really take place until the 1970s
specifically 1973 and the reason why is
because loki in a lot of ways was kind
of ahead of his time right the
potential of a god who was a god of
mischief and the kind of chaos he could
invoke
across the world was something that had
great potential but because of the
storytelling nature of stan lee and jack
kirby it was never really
seen to its full potential but all this
changed in 1973 and the reason why was
because
in 1971 gwen stacy died and this is one
of the things we've talked about before
and i will say the death of gwen stacy
didn't have a direct
impact on loki's character in comics but
it had a huge
impact on how marvel wrote comics
because up to that point there had never
been an instance in comic books
where a superhero had failed so
disastrously that their love interest
died right that was just kind of a no-no
that was something that just
never happened and it didn't matter who
it was right it was a hallmark of comic
books ever since the the early days of
action comics tried action comics number
one lois lane's in danger
superman saves her right every single
time without fail but the idea that gwen
stacy died and seemingly the way that
jerry conway did it was by spider-man
shooting his webbing into her foot and
her neck
snapping and then you kind of get this
other statement by the green goblin
saying she was already dead that's still
a topic that's debated among fans as to
whether or not she was dead before her
neck broke but assuming that you
you go with the ladder and you assume
that spider-man broke her neck then
ultimately
spider-man ended up killing his love
interests and failing in that way and so
because of that
it totally changed comic books now that
was kind of a precursor
to stories like the dark knight returns
over at dc comics and even the death of
superman in 1992
it's kind of the story that not a lot of
people highlight but is exceedingly
important
because it ushered in this age of
writing darker stories and this is one
of the things that kind of led into
chris claremont when he took over the
x-men being able to write
darker more cerebral and more gritty
stories involving the superhero team
that had previously been kind of written
as like pretty white kids with problems
by stanley and jack kirby but
nonetheless you know kind of back on
track here talking about loki the reason
why this matters is that in 1973
you got a crossover event that was
essentially spearheaded by steve
inglehart that was called the avengers
defenders war now the defenders were not
really an avengers-esque team but in my
mind in a lot of ways they were actually
more powerful
right you had the silver surfer you had
the incredible hulk you had name of the
submariner dr strange you had the
original fire lord
i think it was a pretty it was a it was
a heavy hitting team right it was
something comparable to like the
annihilators that you had in marvel
comics the the whole thing about this is
that loki had essentially teamed up with
dormammu
and then tricked the avengers and the
defenders into going to war
over an artifact that was called the
evil eye now the evil eye already did
have a bit of history with guys like
presterjohn and with guys like dane
whitman also known as black knight who
you guys will be seeing coming up
relatively soon in the marvel cinematic
universe but in the aftermath of the
stories
involving dane whitman and preston
john's ultimately the evil eye was
broken up into six pieces and scattered
across the globe the idea of
loki teaming up with dormammu in order
to send the avengers and the defenders
after the the pieces of the evil eye is
that when it's assembled it would allow
its wielder to manipulate matter
on a atomic level right it would just
allow them to control
essentially everything across the
universe it'd be like having the reality
stone assuming you could push it to that
point the result of this is that or at
least the the
main goal behind this was for earth to
be pulled into the dark dimension of
dormammu and basically the entire
superhero community to be destroyed that
also works you know as far as loki went
because loki hated the various
superheroes on earth and wanted to see
them destroyed as well
ultimately loki and dormammu were
defeated by the avengers and the
defenders when
they teamed up but this was one of those
moments when the schemes of loki almost
led to the destruction of the world and
it was a pretty cool concept
right up to that point in time loki's
schemes hadn't really gotten to that
level they weren't really on the point
where it was like loki was a credible
threat that could lead to the world's
destruction that's one of the reasons
why
avengers defenders is such a significant
story among comic book fans
one because it was a crossover between
two teams that people wanted to see
crossover at the time anyway and two
because it elevated loki beyond being a
simple trickster that just kind of
caused some havoc for thor and
occasionally did some crazy things to
being a guy who was a legitimate global
threat and an
actual threat to all of humanity itself
now following that you basically picked
up in the mid-1980s
and one of the other significant moments
of loki albeit more comedic now this
took place during walt simonsen's run
on thork and for those of you guys who
are unaware walt simonson's run on thor
is considered to be one of the most
significant runs ever written for the
character and a lot of this is because
of the fact that again walt simon was
writing a more a more grounded thor
story right focusing a lot on the thor
mythos it kind of piggybacked a little
bit off the old tales of asgard stories
that were initially started by jack
kirby and then later written by stan lee
which basically kind of told the whole
backstory of asgard how it came to be
and how we got to the modern era and
different things like that but walt
simonson's run
also introduced the idea of like a true
ragnarok happening in the thor mythos
that was some you know something
relatively close
to how ragnarok was supposed to unfold
in the real world mythos of thor and
odin and asgard and all that kind of
stuff it was not a one for one ratio i
do want to point that out it was not
an incoming book adaptation exactly the
way that it's that it's supposed to play
out in the real world he wasn't like
that right it was comic books there were
different liberties that were taken
based on the characters as they'd been
created and written by stan lee and jack
kirby but one of the more important
things that happened here was in issues
364 to 366 which came out in 1986 that
basically gave us throg
where loki pulled off a scheme where he
turned thor into a frog now
it was cool right because you literally
had like little frog thor
and like he had a little mjolnir with
him it was adorable i'm not even gonna
lie
it was like the cutest thing and the
funny thing about this is throg actually
returned as a separate character right
because it's one of those concepts where
fans i mean fans don't take it seriously
fans aren't like oh man throgs here
things are about to pop off right nobody
ever really says that but it's just one
of those funny little moments right it's
one of those little characters that come
about fans like oh cool throg
that's awesome but that's kind of how
fans usually respond to his character
marvel comics i know i do right but
again it was small little moments like
that right just kind of screwing with
thor messing with thor but then you go
into another
major significant moment for loki which
was really just kind of loki being used
as a catalyst for mobile comics to
initiate yet another long-awaited
crossover it was a two-part story
written by chris claremont in 1985 going
to 1986 which was the x-men
alpha flight crossover event but the way
this played out and this is actually one
of the first appearances or the first
appearance
of the ones who sit above in shadow in
marvel comics and we'll talk about them
here in a minute but loki basically met
with this group for the purpose of
increasing his own powers in order to
make his schemes to destroy thor and
ultimately take over asgard even easier
and so the way this happened
is that the ones who sat above and
shadow promised loki an upgrade to his
power
but only if he was able to perform a
good deed and so what he ended up doing
was creating something called the fire
fountain which would basically either
boost the powers of those who already
had powers or give powers to those who
didn't have them at all
and so the first people to receive
abilities here or boost to their
abilities rather were cyclops and
madeleine pryor and then seemingly
everybody on their airline or on the the
passenger airliner they were on
received powers as well now the way the
airliner went down
was reminiscent to cyclops of a member
of alpha flight known as the shaman
and so because of that it was believed
alpha flight took down the passenger
airliner that cyclops and madeline pryor
on nobody really knew why and initially
the x-men thought it was like an
assassination attempt
and so ultimately the x-men confront
alpha flight and then a fight breaks out
they realize
something else is going on here they
team up they discover it's loki
loki's defeated but this was again
another instance where it wasn't really
loki himself
doing anything major insofar as like
facing off against alpha flight and the
x-men single-handedly but it was one of
these moments where loki had instigated
a conflict and again
kind of brought along a crossover that a
lot of fans wanted to see in marvel at
the time
and so following that you probably go
into one of the more significant moments
of classic loki's history which was in
1989 and 1990. and anybody who's
familiar with comic books at this point
in time
knows exactly what story i'm getting
ready to talk about and his acts of
vengeance so for those of you guys who
are unfamiliar acts of vengeance was a
line-wide crossover event in marvel
comics those of you guys who don't know
what that means whenever you have
crossover events in marvel usually
you'll have like a crossover between a
couple of different teams or a couple of
different characters right you know the
idea of characters teaming up that was
the whole basis behind marvel two and
one from back in the day the important
thing about this
is that this line-wide crossover event
was essentially all the titles in marvel
comics and that's why acts of vengeance
is considered one of these seminal
stories right it's the first time for
example that peter parker got the the
power
of the enigma force and became captain
universe different things along those
lines right a lot of changes were
ushered into characters
because of the axe of engine story but
in reality when you break it down for
what it is
it's really just old man logan before
old man logan but on a larger scale so
what ended up happening here is
loki in an effort to destroy the
avengers had actually disguised himself
as a random stranger
and then met with the various villains
of of marvel comics now when i see the
various villains i mean
the top tier villains right the creme de
la creme of the superhero community so
basically the villains are the most
popular heroes right the most popular
villains of the most popular heroes and
loki essentially put them all together
you know brought them all together and
then had them
switch enemies so that that heroes so
like magneto for example
would not necessarily face off against
uh against the x-men different things
along those lines
and so the way this played out is that
once everybody came to the realization
that loki was the one behind this well
then all the fighting stopped with the
villains then everybody kind of turned
on loki but it was stories like that
that
led to him becoming this character that
was really elevated to being hugely
popular among fans and a lot of people
really coming to this realization that
loki
if written by the right person could be
a powerhouse in marvel comics now the
downside to this is you go into the
1990s
and as most of you guys know the 1990s
was a time of chaos for marvel comics so
to kind of break away from loki here for
a second give you guys a little bit of
history uh which actually kind of goes
into the origin of how the mcu came
along if you're interested in that that
marvel comics was basically going broke
in the 1990s right and we're not going
to go into a
great big huge discussion as to why
there were a lot of moving parts there
but in essence marvel comics flooded the
market with comic books right and people
were basically buying comics in the
hopes they would increase in value over
time when that stopped happening people
stopped buying and
as with any company when people stopped
buying that company's product the
company starts going broke this led to
guys like aviarot and ike perlmutter
stepping in
and then backing marvel financially but
one of the things that marvel also did
is they actually outsourced the creation
of a lot of their comics to a company
called event publications and event
publications was a company created
by two guys named joe casada and jimmy
palmiotti but because they were
instrumental in keeping marvel afloat
the reward for jokasada's efforts
is that when a new editor-in-chief was
selected in 1999 going into 2000
joe casada was given the spot but when
quesada came into marvel comics his
stance was
this place is too chaotic right like one
of the reasons why the comedy bus
happened is because there's way too many
mutants peter parker is being aged by
his marriage with mary jane watson right
like this
all these different things are going on
we need to basically like thin the herd
right we need to skim down marvel comics
and so he essentially sought to undo
all that stuff right so one of the first
things that happened is the marriage
between peter parker and mary jane
watson was nullified in a story called
spider-man one more day which spider-man
fans still can't get over and i don't
understand why
the next thing that happened is jokasada
implemented an event called
house of m or the scarlet witch reduced
the mutant population
down to two percent of what it
previously was basically 198 mutants
that went into the whole house of m
and decimation era which was essentially
the aftermath of all those mutants
losing their powers one of the other
things that happened is you saw the
entire removal or disbanding
of the avengers team right the avengers
disassembled but as a compliment to that
story
you got thor disassembled and thor
disassembled is one of the most
important stories with classic loki uh
and really where we start to end our
video here
the events leading up to that
specifically in the 1990s dan jurgens
had been riding thor
and during the end of his run you had
odin who died facing off against surter
and so as a result of that
loki basically led a campaign against
asgard with surter along
along with a whole host of asgardians
enemies and essentially taking out
asgard itself right now
this story also saw a massive power
boost for thor but only in a limited
capacity and the way this played out is
that once thor was defeated by the
forces of loki and loki essentially took
the throne of asgard and became the new
asgardian king that you had this event
unfold whereby he was greeted with the
power of odin right the odin force
and it essentially guided him on this
kind of quest the same journey that odin
undertook to gain his wisdom his power
all that kind of good stuff and then
when thor did that he essentially used
what were called the nornstones these
artifacts that if they're used correctly
can boost the power of a person to on on
a massive level and it actually elevated
thor
to a multiversal scale thor ended up
meeting the ones who sit above in shadow
and then realize the cycle of ragnarok
was perpetual right and it had gone on
essentially for infinity right that
asgard
had constantly been destroyed and been
reborn and the ones who sit above in
shadow
actually feed on that energy and so in
order to stop the cycle of ragnarok thor
essentially destroyed all the asgardians
as well as asgard itself when he
destroyed the world tree idracil
and so as a result of that thor himself
perished and that basically led into the
return of thor
during jake michael cerzinski's run as
well as loki coming back in the form of
a woman but for this part of the video
we're gonna bring this to an end if you
guys are new here to comments explained
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
you